[Music]
my whole life I would watch him arena
suit you could pick up a grown man with
one hand Aramis fist is a zebra and he
told me he was to order to carry the
mantle of Panda he would pass it to me
and just be king he told me he was too
fat to fit their suit I told him not to
speak either you had
he taught me not to trust the outside
world where did he change his views
time it has a way of making you look
back on the things that you have done do
you ever look back at your time as a war
dog test no the outside world is too
unpredictable for a lord been like me
a gyros
your highness
oh yeah i oh please give us a second
listen it's not my place to say
yeah I really don't think you should do
this what you guys have is gonna scare a
lot of people in that way we're gonna
come after you
yes but I will no longer rule after fear
not ours or anyone elses yeah I figured
you'd say that
well okay I'll do my best to keep up
your back I'm gonna hold you to that
everything I see in there or T'Challa
I'm Adam Sandler
Nancy Calello
it was close it was close no map I
practice back in a banana double date
howdy Prince he's gonna division while
got beat you
come forward
you and Nakia are not to play in the
catacombs T'Challa
I'm sorry Baba what is wrong mother
I was forced to make a difficult choice
today you taught me that every choice a
king makes is difficult but some choices
are harder than others I'm sure you did
what is right for Wakanda you always do
what a great king babar that is why you
will always hurry
always but what about when I get old
then gray and past comes to carry me off
to the ancestors but then I'll be
Panther now beat them back with my
Panther claws
so here's the scene that I was
incredibly proud of as a director but
you know just didn't work inside of the
side of the confines of our of our film
obviously the scene between the
characters a Quay in a copy and I'm in
are making a scene was the attention for
the audience to really realize that that
equation will cog we're husband and wife
um so I had it kind of had a
confrontational argument about where
Wakanda was gonna go after two challahs
death you know in the in the in the in
the tribal council room I was it was a
scene with the incredible performances
from from from Danai gurira and Daniel
Kuya but it just didn't working it in
the film but I'm really excited for
folks that folks to see it anyway
boy what charla improbable yaku am you
didn't seem to have a problem when he
was thrown from the force
he was the king's challenge he lost he
wanted him to lose he was not fit to
lead each other told me to my face right
here if you bring claw back did he do it
he had him the Jackass stole him from
Alec I don't care
crossbow from us he made my mother and
father 30 years there's been not justice
and he shall I swore to bring him back
not taken to the UN not taken to the CIA
but bring here to us
this is what you would have me leave the
door for to bring our children into this
world where they become conquerors yes
that children will be leaders of a truly
free world not just a tiny country where
we have to hide everything that makes us
great growing war and death but in the
end it will be beautiful makanda will
stand tall
female leadership is very prominent I
love the idea of society with so much
tradition and so much respect for women
these female characters mark Rebney
importance to the child in important to
the country over condi
T'Challa oculist field of women and his
advisors over some women the right is
good women at the forefront is brilliant
life son it is your time that play out
one of my dreams to show an
african-american woman in this light as
the queen as the mother Ramona is the
person that reassures to challenge that
he's ready
well Kota forever being a mother myself
understand the relationship knowing
their strengths their weaknesses trying
to support him I think that that's a
really exciting thing to see is a proud
African woman she brings a sort of
gravitas art history to the position and
her relationship were both T'Challa and
Sheree feel like a real family
I'm here with my son - John
[Music]
[Music]
we wanted to give you some really cool
heady designs and heady sci-fi ideas
coming out of the technology of Wakanda
I really wanted to be thoughtful about
where it had come from and take the
ideas from Kirby and just bring them
into the 20th century things like the
inner crafts that we could pull out and
be specific about we didn't want it to
be like a spaceship because you're not
in space but we wanted it to feel like a
very luxurious aircraft that has all of
the bells and whistles of vibranium can
give it
remote access oil being updated to
interface directly with my same table
Kamiya beets are like a condom version
of a cell phone where is to China this
kimono beads have been switched off
computer and all-in-one
this was stabilizing funda in Black
Panther mythology the dorm la hair is
somewhat like the Navy SEALs they're the
best fighters in Wakanda and they're all
women we had to find a group of girls
that embodied with Marvel and Ryan is
looking for I called it finding Dora we
spent months trying to locate and come
down to our final Dora we started
looking into the fight world
the track and field world and the
dancing world so interesting to bring
all these women together to create an
army we all have to shave our head so of
course in Philly a sister that's what
would everyone has a shave did aah
squealing this will go quickly and I can
get this particular that's my head
[Music]
my training is so great because you have
to learn a way of combat and a way of
movement that is really going to look
and feel like someone who knows what the
heck they're doing I got you good
we would do stunt training every day
with the girls who were playing the
doors it was tough it was a hard we're
able to find a beautiful grace in these
women and also a ferocity fighting is
like by any means necessary we think
you're not a throne guys like twice your
size so I like to start star movies our
projects are we like what like a
question that I need to try to find the
answer to that you know when was the
concept of what does it mean to be
African you know one of the first things
I said and then I was like I got it
eleganza continent no I've been yet I
had feeling that you know in trying to
ground Wakanda in the real world same
way that if she was grounded in the real
world and a lot of your other stories
you know um no I would need to kind of
get to get there you know I mean to see
it for myself I was also interested in
this idea which has been exploring the
comics if we can't exist you know if
somebody told me what kind of being here
this whole time right how would that
make me feel like kill manga yeah you
know it's just that like that idea that
idea of wait so this place has been
there but all these things have been
happening you know nothing's nothing's
been done about it your honor that's a
that's a conflict that becomes very
interesting so the other thing we got
into was it was his idea and I am I my
brother's keeper
you know which is the question you know
in or do you even see people as your
brother you know me and I give if you
you know in this idea of some
preservation and what that means for
people who were born outside at all his
lives so now I got a litany of stuff
that we found to be relevant to the time
know colonization borders identity the
idea in the culture the african-american
versus no existed in direct conflict
with the culture of the average so
that's what we started to get into some
rich stuff tomorrow
that's when we started to get excited hi
i'm ryan coogler director of black
panther it was important to me to bring
Marvel's first african-american
superhero to life on the big screen
because i grew up as a comic book fan
let her be kind of a fan of comic book
movies were
being made but I just wanted to see
characters who look more like me more
like my family more like my friends and
I was kind of hot was introduced to the
Black Panther in the first place he said
especially placing my heart ever since
so an opportunity came to make this film
I kind of jumped at it one of the
biggest things for me with the film was
really looking at the theme of what it
means to be African it was a thing that
I was trying to answer for myself not
just as an artist but as a person but we
think that it's a film that's about
humanity overall that people will be
able to connect with regardless of where
they from where they heritage is
something that's present in the comic
book style you really wanted to make
sure they'll be highlighted in the film
or sad I have really amazing female
characters that are strong and have the
operation positions in society that you
have reminded of the Queen Mother of
Wakanda Cherie
Arlie scientist Nakia an international
spy okay at the head of the Dorma logic
and so we were able to make a society
that functions maybe in a way that we
wish society could at the heart of black
panther it's really about a man who's
accepting his role in society coming
into his own was a film about family
it's a film about responsibility about
culture but at the end of the day most
of film about what it means to be human
thanks for watching I really hope that
you guys all enjoy the film
[Music]
why I was really particular about how to
tell the story of Wakanda actually going
to Africa once a continent was extremely
important for us because that's where
little hearted a narrative takes place
Brian is a super visual person
he has gone to write he was in Africa
and it really started with him just
sending me pictures pictures of like the
bells on people's ankles pictures of
show but people were wearing you have
different masks so it was just us going
back and forth I knew it was something
that we could recreate from a place of
fantasy a place of African culture and
place of imagination the world is
changing the outside world is catching
up and soon it will be the conquerors or
a complete
kondeh it's not necessarily homogeneous
group of people the different tribes
with different points of view and each
tribe have their own agendas so now we
get into the sort of geopolitics of
wakanda there are people that don't
believe that we kind of sit even be out
in the world unless people know about
what cons of it better from their
perspective which is becoming more and
more a challenge in this day and age if
the world ever were to find out what
they have both in the natural resources
and technology all of a sudden they're
gonna be under the spotlight and then
what happens then how do you rule that
nation for hundreds of years now we've
been living outside of the popular
society but now what Conda is
potentially gonna succumb to our
globalization and reach out to the
outside world yo dis yours
the story is very relevant we need a
greater understanding about each other
we need to bring some life back to the
differences in our cultures because we
all really do live here and we all live
here together the 1970s the first Black
Panther service was being done
you weren't obviously a lot of black
characters pop culture was not where it
is now as you guys doing this from I
wish we had the backing in terms of
people believing in the project they
felt they would give me a book that was
going to die
the Black Panther wasn't an important
character but the reason that we got to
do what we did was because they didn't
have time to read those books the Quran
I think about three forces in and then
said hey wait a minute but it was too
late it's already a novel and then I
could do it what made it unique was just
the idea at the time
not only was this a black superhero and
it was kind of a shock when he's pulls
off his mask and reveals himself to be
an African King but he's also rich very
smart yeah the king of a kingdom and he
single-handedly defeats Marvel's premier
family group the Fantastic Four and this
was all being done and delivered to a
largely white and male audience at the
time so it was kind of a shock wave in a
sense and delivered at a time of civil
unrest during the growth of the civil
rights movement and it just showed what
a progressive thinker Stan was and still
is to this day
[Music]
and